INFECTED HAD NOT BEEN
VACCINATED.
TONIGHT A FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE.
WE GREET AN AFGHAN COMBAT
TRANSLATOR AND HIS FAMILY AS
THEY ARRIVE IN THE U.S.
THIS COMES AS THOUSANDS OF OTHER
INTERPRETERS, DESPERATELY SEEK
VISAS TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN
BEFORE THE LAST U.S. TROOPS ARE
GONE AND TALIBAN COMES TO HUNT
THEM DOWN.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS THE STORY
TONIGHT.
>> MILITARY VETERANS FROM NO ONE
LEFT BEHIND WAITED THREE HOURS
AT DULLES INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO GREET THIS
TRANSWHO RISKED HIS LIFE FOR THE
U.S. FOR YEARS AND FINALLY
RECEIVED HIS SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA TO THE U.S. ON MAY 27TH AS
THE U.S. TROOPS HASTEN THEIR
WITHDRAWAL.
FEARFUL THE TALIBAN WILL TARGET
HIS FAMILY BACK IN AFGHANISTAN,
HE ASKED THAT WE REFER TO HIM BY
A PSEUDONYM, WE WILL CALL HIM
SADIQ.
>> ALTHOUGH IT WAS A LONG
JOURNEY FOR US, THE VISA PROCESS
TOOK A LONG TIME, LIKE THREE AND
A HALF YEARS.
BUT FINALLY THEY MADE IT.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL NOW THAT YOU
ARE HERE?
>> I FEEL SAFE, YOU KNOW.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD BECAUSE I
SURVIVED --
>> THEN THERE WAS SAM AN IRAQI
TRANSLATOR WHO BECAME THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FIRST SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA RECIPIENT IN 2006
AND NOW SERVES IN THE U.S. AIR
FORCE.
HE CAME TO WELCOME SADIQ AND HIS
FAMILY TO AMERICA.
>> I WAS IN THEIR SHOES ONE DAY
OVER 15 YEARS AGO.
I REALLY APPRECIATED THE FACT
THAT I WAS WELCOMED BY A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND THOSE WHO MADE ME
FEEL THAT THIS IS MY HOME NOW.
>> SAM TESTIFIED IN 2007 ABOUT
THE DANGERS FACED BY THOSE
WORKING WITH THE U.S. MILITARY.
SENATOR TED KENNEDY TOOK UP HIS
CASE IN THE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA PROGRAM WAS BORN.
>> I HONESTLY BELIEVED I WOULD
BE KILLED.
MY NAME WAS LISTED ON THE DOORS
OF SEVERAL MOSQUES CALLING FOR
MY DEATH.
>> FOR SADIQ WHO ARRIVED WITH
HIS WIFE AND FOUR CHILDREN FOR A
NEW LIFE IN THE U.S. SPONSORED
BY THE NONPROFIT KEEPING OUR
PROMISE ROCHESTER, HIS FORTUNE
IS BITTERSWEET.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
WE HOPE THAT THEY SHOULD NOT GET
FORGOT AND THEY SHOULD GET FULLY
SUPPORTED AND THEY SHOULD
RECEIVE THEIR VISA LIKE ME AND
COME TO THE UNITED STATES AND
START THE BETTER LIFE.
>> WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THE U.S.
DOESN'T BRING THEM HERE?
>> THE BAD GUYS WILL FIND THEM
AND THEY WILL KILL THEM.
>> I HAVE SEEN THIS SCENARIO IN
IRAQ.
I WOULD HATE TO SEE IT HAPPEN
AGAIN IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY WOULD MOST CERTAINLY BE
TARGETED BY TALIBAN AND KILLED
AS A RESULT.
>> U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THERE IS
NO PLAN TO EVACUATE THESE AFGHAN
TRANSLATORS.
>> EVACUATION IS THE WRONG WORD.
WE ARE DETERMINED TO MAKE GOOD
ON OUR OBLIGATION TO THOSE WHO
HELPED US.
>> BUT THE U.S. EMBASSY VISA
SECTION IS CLOSED FOR INTERVIEWS
DUE TO COVID.
LAWMAKERS ARE DEMANDING
PRESIDENT BIDEN ACT.
>> IF HE DOESN'T ACT AND HE
DOESN'T GET THESE PEOPLE OUT,
BLOOD WILL BE ON HIS HANDS.
AND ON HIS ADMINISTRATION'S
HAND.
>> THERE IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE
AT PLAY HERE.
THE AMERICAN HANDSHAKE HAS TO
MEAN SOMETHING.
>> 18,000 AFGHANS WHO RISKED
THEIR LIVES FOR THE U.S. ARE
STILL WAITING.
AT DULLES AIRPORT, JENNIFER
GRIFFIN, FOX NEW